we start in Israel where prime minister
Benjamin Netanyahu was in crisis talks
with members of his Coalition local
media say he was planning to suspend a
controversial judicial overhaul an
announcement was expected in the past
hour but that has now been delayed his
far-right Coalition partner item has
urged him not to back down earlier
Israel's president called on the
government to stop the plan immediately
the proposed legislation has sparked
weeks of anti-government protests
Natasha grename joins us now live from
West Jerusalem and it's been an
incredibly chaotic morning uh Netanyahu
was due to speak it's been postponed
their strikes protests what's the latest
we're in a country in crisis an
unprecedented crisis at that I am near
the knesset and as you'll see people are
arriving protesters people opposed to
this judicial overhaul for what's
expected to be a large demonstration
near the knesset we're also told later
today that members of supporters rather
of the government and in favor of this
judicial overhaul are also expected to
protest here near the knesset it is
unclear if that is going to create
clashes and difficulties on the ground
what we do know is this the conversation
has shifted since Netanyahu ousted
defense minister joab Gallant the
conversation has shifted from hitting
the pause button on this judicial
overhaul package one of the most
controversial policies in Israeli
history to now some people calling for
the removal of prime minister Netanyahu
you have a former prime minister Ehud
Barack calling for a ninja Yahoo's
removal you have a member of the
governing Coalition Avatar Lieberman
saying that it is time for Netanyahu to
step down and for another prime minister
to be selected within the LA Coupe party
so what you're seeing are fissures
within the governing Coalition and a
deepening of the divisions within the
Coalition we started to see early this
morning after the news broke concerned
senior members of the governing
Coalition saying that they were in
complete shock that Netanyahu had fired
Gallant that they thought that Netanyahu
had made a strategic mistake and now
you're hearing that some people within
the governing Coalition believe that
this judicial overhaul needs to be
suspended and that's what the removal of
galat was allegedly about gallat had
said for the sake of the country for
preserving National Security hit the
pause button on this judicial overhaul
for about a month until after the
Passover holiday and the Independence
Hall day ends in late April but there's
simply been no room for compromise or
negotiation with Netanyahu and his
governing Coalition and that has brought
us here to this moment as you said he
was expected prime minister Netanyahu
was expected to make a statement to the
country that has been also paused at the
moment well the only thing we have heard
from Netanyahu so far was a tweet early
this morning saying that we must stand
up strongly against the refusals we've
also heard that the airport has been
closed departures from the airport have
been halted what more can you tell us
about that and and those strikes
um I guess going to escalate further to
other Industries
well you mentioned the airport coming to
operations there coming to a standstill
at Ben Gurion Airport in Tel Aviv this
should give you an indication again of
the fissures within the supporters of
the government the head of the Union at
the airport is actually a liquid member
we have a strike today across many
sectors of Israeli Society there are
strikes among High School Middle School
University students there are doctors
that have called in sick so as you can
see this has impacted Israelis greatly
they have been for months making their
voices heard those who oppose this
judicial overhaul saying that they
believe that it's a reach an overreach
by netanyahu's government they're
concerned that by giving this is what
the judicial reform would include by
giving more power to the government to
select Supreme Court Court Justices and
to override decisions that the gov or
the Supreme Court makes regarding
legislation that it will remove
necessary check on power for a branch of
government and I should mention as we're
waiting for Netanyahu to speak as rumors
are swirling that perhaps he's ready to
compromise and hit the pause button on
this judicial reform the Constitution
Law And Justice committee met this
morning and they did approve a law that
would now allow the government to have
an ultimate say in who sits on the
Supreme Court okay thank you very much
for that update that's Natasha canaim
for us in West Jerusalem we'll no doubt
be talking to you throughout the day
there
let's bring in political analysts to
Kiva Elder he joins us from Tel Aviv
thank you again for being on Al Jazeera
it's been described as a crisis in
Israel how would you describe what's
going on uh in the last few hours there
actually this is a process that started
uh since
decision to outset Garland who is one of
the members of his political family he's
uh not just another member of knesset or
another Minister he was there standing
behind a taniel in court with a match
during the corona period supporting him
when he made those very controversial
statements against the Israeli Judiciary
and uh you cannot accuse him of being
so-called anarchists and I can say that
Nathaniel's career has been built up
always on both fear and hatred of the
other and now Netanyahu became the other
and you don't see his supporters in the
streets he is very lonely he is losing
his uh party and he will probably lose
his Coalition because he's now cornered
by his
right-wing extra large right-wing party
Bengal a former terrorist and he will
have to choose between keeping the
liquid together or keeping the Coalition
together
and what we used to say unprecedented
situation I think even unprecedented is
not what it used to be in Israel what do
you think he will choose you say he's
got a choice which why do you think he
he is going to go when he eventually
does make an announcement at some point
today
well um what he could do a few days ago
to agree on a timeout and sit with the
sit down with the opposition and go to
the president and discuss uh you know
how to gain some more time this is
irrelevant today now they are the
opposition and the people in the streets
are demanding to shelves all the
legislation that now are now in the
pipeline so
um he may have to lose not only bankware
and the radical religious rights but
also his Minister of Justice
um I am not sure if he knows
what's the best for him because we have
to keep in mind that the court is also
waiting for him and if it doesn't pass
those personal legislation amendments of
the law
um the the judges on and the Supreme
Court that will eventually have to deal
with his case and that he wanted to
change uh and and put in his uh
supporters uh people from the radical
right
um this is not going to happen so uh I
think that he has to think about his
place in history right now if you really
be remembered as Israel is Putin all you
know uh prime minister who uh brought us
the Abraham records and uh is a very
intelligent human being and I really
feel sorry for him okay thank you we'll
have to leave it there but no doubt
we'll be speaking to you throughout the
day as well there's political analyst to
Kiva Elder from Tel Aviv thank you